منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه اكبر صدمه
تجاريه واقتصاديه شاهدها قطاع السفر الجوي
والطيران هي تفشي فيروس كورونا وبينما
ننتقل الى عام 20 23 يتوقع الاتحاد النقل
الجوي الدولي نتعافى قطع الطيران ويكتسب
زخما في العام المقبل ويعود الى تحقيق
الارباح على الرغم من تجديد الاقتصاد
العالمي مع ارتفاع هذا طلب عرض شركه
ودالتي اون لاين زياده في الاجور
التراكميه بنسبه
34% لطيارها على مدى ثلاث سنوات في عقد
جديد كما وعدت شركه الطيران التي تتخذ
اتلانتا مقر لها ان تتجاوز معدلات رواتب
طيارها مدراءهم في يونايتد لاينز وامريكان
لاينز بنسبه واحده في المئه على الاقل
يذكر ان تيار دلتا لم تتجدد عقودهم لما
يقرب من ثلاث سنوات بعد ان اصبح عقده قديم
قابله للتعديه في ديسمبر 2019 مما ادى الى
اخباره
[موسيقى]
الى الجانب الاقتصادي مع زميله سامر
المصري
[موسيقى]
كبير في قطاع الطيران الاقتصاديا هل يمكن
القول انقطاع عاد الى مستويات ما قبل
الجايه
هو 74% من ما كان عليه في 2019 عوده
الحركه الطيران بشكل عام ولكن طبعا في
مناطق في العالم تختلف عن غيرها مثلا
اليوم مثل ما شفنا في الخبر
دلتا رفعت رواتب الموظفين لانه التعافي في
امريكا بالنسبه للسفر المحلي واحد في
المئه اقل فقط من مستويات 2019 بينما
مقارنه بين 22% في اوروبا ايضا على مستوى
الدولي 10% يعني فقط اقل من مستويات 2019
مقارنه
17% في اوروبا و57% في همم اسيا الان ليش
امريكا طبعا ارتفع وحده من العوامل كان هو
ارتفاع الدورر مقابل باقي العملات فائده
طبعا الى زياده السفر سواء محليا او
عالميا ايضا هذا مثل ما قراتي في الخبر
هذا كل العوامل ادت الى زياده الطلب
والمنافسه على الوظائف في قطاع الطيران
وخصوصا الطيارين اللي كانوا مظلومين يعني
خصوصا في امريكا كانت رواتبهم جدا قليله
في ما يكلف يعني تكلفه باهظه انه يتخرج
كطياره 100,000 دولار 1500 ساعه طيب بدلنا
نتحدث عن الوظائف والطيارين قطاع الطياره
الامريكي اعلن عن نقص حاد في الطياره
الرواتب هي السبب يا سمر وهل هو نقص عالمي
للطيارين هو نقص عالميا من الطيران فعلا
في المنطقه مثلا عندنا نقص خلال السنه
القادمه في الشرق في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
ثلاثه الاف طيار حتى في منطقه في منطقتنا
طبعا هنا كان هي بنفس الوقت هي فرصه ونقص
وفرصه للاتجاه لهذه الوظائف عندك على
مستوى العالم خلال العشر سنوات القادمه
سيكون هناك نقص 80,000 موظف في اا يعني
طيار تحديدا في عندك في امريكا فقط ثمانيه
الاف نقص بالطيارين ليش هذا النقص يصير
اول شيء لانه مثلا في امريكا هم مثل ما
كنا ما كانوا يدفعوا لهم رواتب همم جيده
وتكلف ايضا القانوني يتطلب 1500 ساعه تعمل
في مثلا في يوروب يتطلب القانون 250 ساعه
عمل فقط تراكتس وارخص التكلفه من التخرج
كم مدارس
ايضا اللي صار انه مؤخرا كان هناك اعتماد
في امريكا الطيار الحربي بعد ما يتقاعد من
كونا طيار حربيه يذهب ليصبح طيار مدني
اليوم هناك اعتماد كبير على الدرونز همم
او الطيارات المسيره فسر هناك اقل انخراط
في قطاع الاذريشن او الطيران الحربي في
امريكا ايضا اليوم يمكن لهذا نجد التوجه
حتى في العالم العربي انه هناك دعوه تشجيع
اكثر لدراسه هذا او للقدوم الى هذا القطاع
حتى هناك تشجيع للاناث مرى اليوم المزيد
من الاناث يدخلون في قطاع الطيران
ويتخرجون كالطيارات طب شفنا في قطاع
التيار الامريكي زياده رواتب الطيارين هل
هو الحل لسد الفجوه هل يمكن لشركات شركه
طيران ان تتحمل هذا بعد الخسائر التي
تكبدتها
هو تشجيع دخول المزيد يعني في اوروبا في
امريكا كان هناك نوع من العنصريه ايضا هو
الرجل الابيض هذا القطاع مش في همم خمس
سنوات الفائته كان هناك شويه اقل عنصريه
في هذا المجال كان هناك تشجيع لدخول اكثر
اليوم هناك همم بدل ما يكون في بس الجامع
او مركز مخصص لتعليم الطيران اليوم هناك
شركات الطيران نفسها وهذا بزنس جديد
واليوم يعني يعطي فرصه استثماريه السيده
للكثير من الشركات الطيران خصوصا في
امريكا واوروبا كما هي تفتح مؤسسات خاصه
فيها للتدريب واللجبه هؤلاء الطيارين او
بتكلفه اقل وساعات عمل اقل وشويه هناك
مطالبات عده بتخفيف هذه القيود على ساعات
الطيران المطلوبه قبل ان يتخرج كطيار او
كطيار اا مساعد ايضا هناك مثلا هنا في
المنطقه همم الطيارين في منطقه الميدل
ايست من اكثر ال- همم يعني الاعلى اجورا
مقارنه بينهم ولهذا اليوم المنطقه تشتدبها
هؤلاء الطيارين خصوصا لشركه الطيران
الكبرى فهذه ايضا شيء اخر مثل عندك اير
فرانس رفعت 5% كافي فلسفه رفعت 3% بس طبعا
كلهم بمستويات اميركا اللي رفعت 30% يعني
او اكثر هل يمكن التنفي نفس استراتيجيات
والحلول في منطقه الشرق الاوسط كالتعليم
في شركات الطيران الخاص بالتع- لحد الان
هناك العديد من المعاهد هنا ولكن لحد الان
ليست معاهد مثل اللي موجوده طبعا في
امريكا لا في هناك العديد من المعاهد
المعتمده بالتاكيد بس ما زالت مكلفه جدا
انا من الاشخاص اللي كنت اريد ان ادرس
طيران قبل ما اتخرج يعني قبل ما افوت ما
اجعل المحاسبه بس كانت التكلفه عاليه جدا
وما كان مفتوح للاناث اليوم شوي هذه
التكلفه اقل بس هناك مطالبات بفتح المزيد
من هذه المعاهد بتكاليف معقوله يعني 100
الف دولار تكلفه عاليه للتخرج همم طيار
وبعدين حسب البينتيات تلاقين دائما همم
يعني يدفع هذه التكلفه
فهناك ان شاء الله توجه اكثر ليفتح مثل
هذه المعاهد مع تضخم الفجوال لنجتها اليوم
في قطاع الطياره محلي قوي
شكرا لك